a string of stabbings and murders here
in the valley ends with a Man Behind
Bars police say 33-year-old Christopher
Martell killed two people and injured
two others in a stabbing spree near UNLV
over an eight day period 8 news now
reporter Ryan Matthey is at Regional
Justice Center where Martel was supposed
to appear before a judge
well Christian Martell's accused of
targeting homeless women who lived alone
all in a string of violent crimes
including stabbings and murders that
have police questioning if there are
other violent crimes he could be tied to
Martel Christopher 33 year old
Christopher Martell declining to appear
in court Thursday he's accused of three
separate stabbing incidents over the
past week the first near University
Avenue and Tamaris Street last Wednesday
where police found a homeless woman
stabbed to death outside a Southeast
Valley business the next this past
Tuesday a deceased 74 year old homeless
woman found with several stab wounds on
a nearby sidewalk this confirmed it that
this was likely the same suspect as he
walks towards the same area that's when
the crimes were pieced together says
Metro Police Lieutenant Jason Johansen
security footage around the area shows a
man leaving each scene with a knife in
the same direction before escaping off
camera near Rochelle Avenue police then
adding extra cameras and Patrol to
respond we believed that he was
targeting possibly targeting unhoused
females who are living in the area then
Wednesday night those along Flamingo
Road and Burnham Avenue witnessing a man
coming up from behind and stabbing a
woman who's pushing an elderly man in a
wheelchair in both their necks and torso
newly installed cameras identifying the
man before police apprehended him during
his Escape was the black puffer jacket
the black fedora the brown boots police
finding the knife suspected in the first
two murders on him a search warrant of
his apartment where he lives alone
revealing clothes first seen on security
footage and forensic evidence matching
those from the first two stabbings but
the question remains why the stabbings
at all we don't know yet in terms of
motive and we won't be able to discuss
the the interactions in terms of the
interview at this time because we want
to maintain the Integrity of the
prosecution
foreign
say it's common practice to review open
cases to see if there's any possible
connection they do confirm that's
happening with Martel but would not
confirm if they've found anything just
yet reporting live outside the Regional
Justice Center Ryan mathie 8 News Now